welcome to this video playing swap yeah
grab an international master Miller from
Germany he study does not have the title
in there I don't know why it's a bit
strange
check yeah but other things if he
doesn't have the title in the s2 to pay
for this account okay so we have the the
whenever with Knight f3 I'm going to try
to trade off my bishop yep I'm going to
manage that which does not mean that I
don't have to play h6 at the mode which
does not mean that okay now is he trying
to try to use that okay so if I go age
60 M Queen age 5 or what this is a DM
that's half not to play this move so g6
sending sending him back yeah how does
black play this knight Knight a5 or
season it doesn't do very much Bishop e3
might be coming okay at least he never
has Queen f3 or something like that
if he goes Knight f3 hmm he's not
threatening Bishop h6 okay 197 is mostly
played to cover c5 so that I'm like
Bishop e3 is not coming with an attack
on the pawn hmm yeah I don't really know
how this is played
do you King King f8 King g7 is this is
totally off probably
rather the dark squares as usual are the
problem in the Vanara rookie one
taking deform no don't really know okay
it's just going back so g4 is this
coming maybe it is but it is also
weakening with him
so that's gorgeous rook c8 look at the
horns on this ecology for I drop back he
cannot take age 62 to 98 pinning this
piece I think
they don't know if chief is doing much
good if he cannot take on age six
oh that's a that's a good move probably
with these coming with d5 him
they take on we will take on d5 or play
d4 d5 and then the the roux condom once
the file will be very very dangerous
mmm-hmm that's that's a very very
dangerous
whoa
I don't see a player continuation yeah
it looks that looks really really really
bad strong move
and okay so night chicks I was thinking
look see three years maybe a some source
for counterplay if him if he has to play
a probably has to play a pawn move now
or queen g4 anyway Queens your form
yeah as Queen d4 is threatened
ah 495
yeah that looks really really bad okay
yeah that was a very nice movie for this
is the danger of the winner I always
have a bad King position and then oh
let's say we dark squares that in
combination with the King often often
the problem I can just go these six
maybe one might be three is to somehow
somehow saving maybe maybe like these
three is at least a threat gem takes I
don't have enough for the exchange if I
take C one unfortunately maybe take with
the pawn okay well maybe I should have
played whoopsie for I don't know
it's playing this very forcefully maybe
that's good I don't know but I have a
number of points no really time 186
still F equal takes
rook c8 king e7 I don't know maybe I can
survive that but it looks it looks very
shaky and I only have 40 seconds but he
has to do that otherwise I'm canceling
Roxy ADIS is the move
I think Czech takes on h8 I guess what
what else is there
check
yeah check
check
Jim defending this is not exactly fun
yeah I did it wasn't worse actually at
one point but still still pretty bad of
course
check-check
all right so check it some of the chick
Czech girl offered a girl offered gained
today I'm going to win this on time you
know he's just not quick enough as why I
could've drawn yeah I know at seven
against nine but I'm just quick and free
moving and I don't know I mean he
completely killed me him at least that
it's how it looked
okay so rookie one and now I went droops
any when they went here okay yeah maybe
this wasn't good then yeah and now this
is seafoam wow that looks very dangerous
computer is totally unimpressed wants to
take everything yeah probably
when I look at this it looks it looks
okay he's got other ideas though he can
always flick in this move then like here
or wow I had look very very scary but
probably I have to do that huh I mean
what a play this is leading to two big
problems here and then he just took took
Queen d1 yeah and now hmm yeah I was
giving up the exchange and white is
clearly better in any case yeah
I don't know if he is six as good I mean
it is the the aggressive move but but it
gives me a big central pawn okf takes is
better actually okay
and this is lost after Queen g4y ah he's
got this move hmm yeah this is stopping
me from castling and threatening rook c8
something like that is not going to end
well
it's noe six yeah yeah that's a disaster
check yeah yeah I'm hanging on I mean
I'm losing still but it's out it's not
like I have to resign or anything
check check check
yeah at the end I'm just an exchange
down and losing but yeah agreed to it
wrong okay Wow I have faith is very
nicely thanks for watching